I want to continue in Volume 4 and taking up at July 28, 1902.
Continue in my usual state, Louisa said, "I found myself outside of myself, and I found
my adorable Jesus, who not wanting to show me the troubles of the world, told me.
My daughter withdraw, do not want to see the evils of the world which are most grave."
And on saying this, he withdrew me himself, and while carrying me, he repeated, "What
I recommend to you is a spirit of continuous prayer," he said.
The continuous effort of the soul to converse with me, whether with her heart, or with her
mind, or with her mouth, or even with a simple intention.
This renders her so beautiful in my sight that the notes of her heart harmonize with
the notes of mine.
I feel so drawn to converse with this soul that I manifest to her not only the works
at extra of my humanity, but I keep manifesting the works at intra, which my divinity did
in my humanity.
At extra means the external works that Jesus did in his life, and the internal is what
went on in his innermost being, in his divinity.
Not only this, but the beauty that a spirit of continuous prayer makes her acquire is
so great that the devil, as though struck by lightning, remains frustrated in the snares
that he lays to harm the soul.
So the biggest protection we can have is a life of continuous prayer, and that gives
us enormous protection.
So he disappeared then.
So July the 31st, 1902, true charity, or true love must be disinterested.
As I was in my usual state, I saw my adorable Jesus several times, but always in silence.
That means, of course, that he's chastising.
I felt all confused and would not dare to ask him anything, but it seemed that he wanted
to tell me something which wounded his most sacred heart.
Finally, the last time he came, he told me, "My daughter, true love or true charity must
be disinterested."
That means I'm not doing it to gain anything for myself.
And it must be disinterested on the part of the one who does it and on the part of the
one who receives it.
If there is vested interest or self-interest, that mud produces a smoke which blinds the
mind and prevents one from receiving the influence and the effects of true charity.
This is why, in many works that are done, even holy ones, in many charitable cares that
are performed, one feels as though avoid and they do not receive the fruit of the charity
that they do.
That's extremely sad that we would actually do something that really helps other people
and literally gain nothing because our motivation is wrong.
We're trying to get something for ourselves, whether it is a reputation for good, a reputation
for holiness, or some other gain, then we've spoiled everything, absolutely.
To August the 2nd, 1902, during the whole course of his life, Jesus redid everything.
This is very important.
This morning, after letting me struggle very much, all of a sudden my adorable Jesus came
spreading rays of light.
Naturally he spreads rays of light because he is light, one John, one five.
I was invested in that light and I don't know how, but I found myself inside of Jesus.
Who can say how many things I understood inside of that holy humanity?
I can only say that his divinity directed his humanity in everything, and of course
Jesus is showing us this so that we will allow his divine will to govern us in all
our thoughts, words, actions, steps, motivations, everything.
And since in one single instant, the divinity can do as many acts as each of us can do in
the whole period of one's life, and as many acts as one wants to do, I understood with
clarity that because the divinity operated in the humanity of Jesus Christ, during the
whole course of his life, blessed Jesus redid for all souls in general and for each one
individually, everything that each one is obliged to do towards God.
In such a way that he adored God for each one, he thanked him, he repaired him, he glorified
him for each one, he praised him, he suffered, he prayed for each one, and I understood
that everything that each one must do has already been done before in the heart of Jesus.
Of course we have to imitate him and we have to do what he does, so he expects us to fuse
ourselves in the divine will, and to pray like this through with and in Jesus in the
divine will.
So August the 10th 1902, as I am greatly afflicted because of the loss of my highest
good, my poor heart is lacerated continuously and suffers a continuous death.
Now as the confessor came, I was telling him of my poor state and he began to call Jesus
and to place his intention, but no, my mind was left suspended.
It would see as though a flash for a few instance, then they would escape and I would return
inside of myself without seeing Jesus, or God what pain.
But these are pains that one does not even know how to express.
And then after much struggling, he finally came and as I lamented to him, he told me,
my daughter, if you did not know the reason for my absence, perhaps you would have some
reason to lament about my absence.
But since you do know that I am not coming because I want to chastise the world, your
lament is not right.
So here's Jesus taking her off very nicely because she does know that when he doesn't
come that he's chastising the world, he just doesn't accept it.
And Louisa said, what does the world have to do with me?
And Jesus said, indeed it has to do with you because if I come, you tell me, Lord, I myself
want to satisfy you on their behalf, I want to suffer for them.
And since I am most just, I cannot receive the satisfaction of a debt from both one and
the other.
And if I wanted to take the satisfaction from you, the world would do nothing but get worse.
Rather in these times of rebellion, chastisement are so very necessary, that if I do not do
so, darkness will become so thick that all would remain blinded.
While he was saying this, I found myself outside of myself and I saw the earth all full of
darkness, which was barely a few trails of light there.
"What will happen to this poor world?" she said.
It causes one to think much about the most sad things that will happen.
And of course, she doesn't realize that the world is building itself up to what we call
World War I.
September the 3rd, 1902.
This morning as I was in my usual state, I felt a natural illness come to me.
And this illness was so strong that I felt I was dying.
I feared I might be about to pass from time into eternity.
Much more so since Blessed Jesus was hardly coming or at the most only like a shadow.
In fact, if he were coming as usual, I would not be fearing at all.
Therefore, so that I might be in a good position, I prayed the Lord to give me the exercise
of his holy mind, to satisfy for the evils that I might have committed with my thoughts.
And to give me the exercise of his holy eyes, of his holy mouth, his holy hands and his
holy feet and his holy heart and all of his most sacred body, to satisfy for all the evils
that I might have committed and for all the good I was supposed to do and did not do.
Now, that is a very important prayer that we should simply imitate, to ask the Lord in
all of his most sacred members to make up for all that is lacking in us so that we can
be purified and that we can be liberated in order to be one with him.
So while I was doing this, Blessed Jesus came all infestal clothing in the act of receiving
me into his arms and he told me, my daughter, everything I deserved I gave to human beings
and in a special and superabundant way to the one who is a victim soul for love of me.
So Jesus is saying that everything he had, he gave to us, but in a very special way,
his gift is to victim souls who are closer to him than all the rest of us.
"Behold," he said, "anything you want I will give to you and not only to you but to whomever
you want."
So I want to give you John 14, 15 and John 15, 7.
Louisa remembering her confessor said, "Lord, if you take me, I pray you to content father."
He said, "Indeed he has received some recompense for the charity he has done for you and since
he has cooperated, as you come to me into the spirit of eternity, I will give him even
more recompense."
But she said, "My illness was getting more and more vigorous and I felt happy since I
was on the harbor of eternity."
In the meantime, the confessor came and called me to obedience.
I would have wanted to have kept everything quiet, but he forced me to say everything
that is under obedience and came out with the usual refrain that out of obedience I was
not supposed to die.
But in spite of this, the illness didn't go away.
So September the 4th is a very important message.
As I continue to feel ill, I also felt a certain restlessness, and she's got to be
careful of the restlessness because the Lord will only work in peace.
And the restlessness was because of this strange obedience that she's not allowed to die,
as if I could not take flight towards my highest and only good.
With the addition that having to celebrate holy mass, the confessor did not want to give
me communion because of the continuous retching that bothered me.
However, since the confessor had told me that out of obedience I should have Jesus Christ
touch my stomach.
As he came, he touched my stomach and the continuous retching ceased.
The Lord is trying very hard to engage the church there.
The church is very, very reluctant to really be engaged with what is going on.
And so the Lord has to really force the arm of the church.
I mean, the priest really has to understand that when he tells the Lord, he wants to place
the intention for the crucifixion that Louisa will experience it because the Lord will listen
and respond.
And if he asks the Lord to lay hands on Louisa and Healer, the Lord will do it.
What Louisa said, "The illness would not cease."
And Jesus, seeing me so restless said, "My daughter, what are you doing?
Don't you know that if death surprises you, finding you restless, you'd have to go to
purgatory?"
You need to read that, get your book out and read it.
If even just for this restlessness you'd have to go to purgatory, don't you realize
that the vast majority go to purgatory?
In fact, in these writings, Jesus says that nine out of ten souls go to purgatory.
If death surprises you, he said, finding you restless, wouldn't you have to go to purgatory?
In fact, if your mind is not united to mine, if your will is not one with mine, if your
desires are not the same as mine, by necessity you need to purg, and you need to be transformed
completely into me.
So I want to give you Philippians chapter two verses one to ten, let this mind be in
you, which was also in Christ Jesus.
"Therefore," he said, "be attentive, think only of remaining united with me, and I will
think of all the rest."
Now while he was saying this, I saw the church and the pope, and part of it was leaning on
my shoulders.
Now, do you remember back in the 12th century, the pope at the time had a vision of a little
man, and he had put his shoulders to the church, and he was supporting the church, and that
little person was Francis of Assisi.
So at the same time that Louisa is having this relationship with the Lord, Patropio is also
holding the church up in a major way in the 20th century.
So Louisa sees that part of the church is leaning on her, and I also saw the confessor
who pressed Jesus not to take me for now.
So the priests are beginning to realize that Louisa is a very important actor in the whole
of church history and world history at the time.
And blessed Jesus said, "Eveils are most grave, and sins are about to reach such a point as
to no longer deserve victim souls."
I find that very frightening, and I just hope there are some victim souls in the world
today, in the 21st century, otherwise we are in for one hell of a chastisement, because
things have got worse and worse and worse.
"Eveils are most grave," he said, "and sins are about to reach such a point as to no longer
deserve victim souls, that is, the ones who sustain and protect the world before me."
If this point touches justice, indeed, I will take her with me," he said.
And then Louisa realized that everything was conditional.
If people will cooperate, of course, the chastisements won't come.
September 5, 1902, "I continue to feel ill," Louisa said, and the confessor continued to
be resolute, even more, to get upset because I was not obeying him with regard to not dying.
As if she had control over dying or not dying.
And he was praying to the Lord to make my suffering cease.
So at least the priest had started praying, that's a hell, isn't it, that instead of
just feeling that he's a functionary to get her out of the stiffness that she's in,
that he will actually get involved.
On the other hand, Louisa said, "I felt called by blessed Jesus and by the saints and by the
angels to go with them.
And I would find myself with Jesus or with the celestial citizens."
That is an in-out-of-the-body experience.
In this state, she said, "I felt tortured, not knowing myself what to do."
So the priest is pulling her back and Jesus and the angels and the saints are pulling her
forward.
"I was calm," she said, "fearing that if he should take me, I might not be ready to
go speedily to him, so I abandoned myself completely into his hands."
That's Luke 23, 46, "into your hands I commend my spirit."
Now, while I was in this position, I saw the confessor and others praying that I would
not be allowed to die, John 14, 13.
And Jesus said, "My daughter, I feel under violence.
Don't you see how they don't want me to take you?"
That's Matthew 11, 12, "The kingdom of God suffers violence and the violent take it by
force."
And Louisa said, "I too feel under the same violence, under the violence.
I truly, they would deserve a penalty for putting a poor creature into this torture."
And Jesus immediately said, "What penalty do you want me to give them?"
And of course, that puts Louisa in a very difficult position.
And she said, "Not knowing what to say before that inexhaustible found of charity," I
said, "My sweet Lord, since sanctity brings sacrifice with itself, make them saints so
that if nothing else they will obtain their intent of keeping me with them, and I will
obtain the intent of seeing them saints as they would have the patience to feel the pain
that sanctity brings."
I call that holy revenge.
In other words, if they only knew how much suffering goes with sanctity, they might just
change their tune.
I think it's really funny.
On hearing me, Jesus was all pleased, and he kissed me and said, "Brava, my beloved,
you are able to choose the optimum for their good and for my glory."
So for now, we must surrender.
We because Jesus and Louisa are one, we must surrender.
And I reserved for myself another occasion.
He doesn't tell her, of course, that it's years later.
I reserved for myself another occasion to take you quickly, giving them no time to do violence
to us, and he did that in her dying, took her quietly during the night, and people didn't
even know she was dead for a day or so.
Then Jesus disappeared, and I found myself inside of myself with my suffering mitigated
for the most part, and with new vigor as if I was born again.
But God alone knows the pain and the torment of my heart.
I hope at least that he might want to accept the hardness of this sacrifice.
This is the martyrdom of having to stay on the earth while she's actually living in heaven.
I think that can be nothing worse.
So September the 10th, 1902, we're talking about love again, and you keep hearing me
saying that the summary of the 36 volumes is divine will and love.
I thought that blessed Jesus would come back according to the usual way, but what was not
my disillusioned when, after deciding that he wasn't going to take me for now, he began
making me struggle for seeing him, and most of the time it was only a shadow or flash.
Then this morning as I was feeling very tired and exhausted, for the continuous longing and
waiting, it seemed that he came, notice seemed, it's not completely clear.
And transporting me outside of myself, he said, my daughter, you are tired.
Come into my heart and rest, and you will be refreshed.
Now, that's Matthew 11, 28 to 30, all you who are overburdened.
So I drew near to that divine heart and I drank large gulps of milk mixed with most
sweet blood.
And he told me, the prerogatives of love are three, constant love without end, strong
love and the love of God and neighbor bound together.
In these prerogatives, if these prerogatives do not appear in the soul, one can say that
hers is not really the quality of true love.
So Jesus had said, whatever you do to the least of my brethren, you actually do to me.
So the love of God is totally bound up with the love of neighbor.
So October the 22nd, 1902.
We now have threats against Italy.
This morning my adorable Jesus came for a few instance, all indignant.
And he said to me, when Italy has drunk the most fetid filth to the bottom, in other words,
she really wants to go into the dregs in sin.
And it seems to me that Ireland is doing that at the moment, when she has drunk the
most fetid filth to the bottom, to the point of being drowned so much so that they will
say she's dead, she's dead, then will she rise again.
Then becoming more calm, he added, my daughter, when I want something from my creatures, I
infuse in them the natural dispositions in such a way as to change their very nature
into wanting what I want.
So notice we can ask the Lord to infuse into us the dispositions that he wants us to have
so that we will be able to do what he wants.
Therefore he says, remain calm in the state you are in.
So she's been solemnly warned that Italy is in real trouble.
So October the 30th, 1902, this morning as I was in a sea of worries and tears because
of the total abandonment, my highest good, while feeling consumed by the pain, I felt
my mind being estranged and I saw blessed Jesus sustaining my forehead with his hand.
And something like a light which contained many words of truths inside.
Now that light reminds me of blessed Anna Maria Taigi, I don't know if you've heard of Anna
Maria, T-A-I-G-I.
She was an Italian lady who lived at the time of Napoleon and she was just an extraordinary
woman.
She was the mother of six sons and they said that she, they never saw her without at least
one child in her arms.
She did ferocious penance for the church and for the world.
And she was the one who got Napoleon's mother to become a martyr of penance for her son
because she said Napoleon was the scourge of Europe.
And so Napoleon's mother became a very holy woman because of all the penance that she
did for an Napoleon and for Europe.
But the Lord gave Anna Maria a gift which was a globe of light.
And when anybody came to her for advice, and everybody came in the sense that Cardinals,
Bishops and Priests, she was living within walking distance of the Vatican, they came
for advice kings and princes and people in high society and government.
People desperately in need to know what God's will was for themselves and for their country.
They came to her and she only had to look into this ball of light and she could tell
them absolutely both the condition of their own souls and what God was looking for for
them.
There was one very famous case where a very famous, I'm going to call him a prince because
he was very high up in society, came to her and he was a little bit arrogant because sometimes
people at that level can be arrogant when they're dealing with the poor because Anna Maria was
very poor, they had nothing.
And she lived happily in her great poverty.
And so he's a little bit arrogant towards her and she looked into her ball and she said
to him, now I'm naturally enough I'm not quoting, I'm just trying to remember.
She said to him, I wouldn't worry about the country if I were you.
And he said, oh, but my country is being attacked by Napoleon and blah, blah, blah.
She said, don't worry about it.
She said, worry about your own soul, you will meet your savior and your judge in two weeks
time.
That took him down off his pedestal to deal with reality.
She said, it's not for you to deal with Europe.
It's for you to deal with your own soul at this particular time.
And so not only individuals like that but whole countries as you're hearing here can
reach a point where the worst thing that could happen to them is that they would die and
have to face their judge when they're not ready.
So here we have on October the 30th, Louisa is seeing a light in which there are very
many truths involved.
Now, she's going to explain to us that while she's in and out of the body experience, she
understands exactly what is being said to her.
When she comes back into the body, then she finds she's unable to actually express it
to anybody else.
That's perfectly normal and any of the saints who've had an experience like this have said
the same.
I can barely remember this, she said, that when our humanity untied the bond of obedience
with God and which God had placed between himself and the creature, that is, she's talking
about Adam and the fall, a bond which alone united God and man, humanity became dispersed.
And that dispersal of humanity is given to us very graphically in the Bible, in the story
of the Tower of Babel.
And Jesus Christ, taking on human nature, making himself our head, our head in the sense
of the one in charge and our head, meaning the first to go ahead of us.
He came to reunite the dispersed humanity, and with his obedience to the holy divine
will of the Father, he came to join man and God again together.
But this indissolible union is strengthened further according to our obedience to the
divine volition.
So each one of us that enters into the divine will spirituality and is trying to hand over
our will to the Lord all the time.
The more we do this, the more we are actually participating in rebinding humanity to the
divine will.
So November the first 1902, true seriousness is found in religion.
As I was in my usual state, Louisa said, I felt I was going out of myself and I found
a child crying, and also several men.
And one of them more serious took a most bitter drink and gave it to that crying child who
suffered so much in swallowing it that his throat seemed to choke.
Not knowing who he was, out of compassion I took him in my arms saying to him, yet he
is a serious man who did this to you.
Poor little one, come to me, she said, for I want to dry your tears.
And he said to me, because that child is Jesus, true seriousness is found in religion.
So this serious man then is one representing religion.
And true religion consists in looking at one's neighbor in God and at God in one's neighbor.
So I want to give you James 1, 27.
Luke chapter 10 from verse 1.
I want to give you Matthew 22 verses 36 to 40.
You have to look them up yourselves now.
Then drawing close to my ears so much so that his lips actually touched mine and his voice
resounded in my interior.
He said, the word religion is a ridiculous word for the world, and it seems to be worth
nothing.
Yet before me, every word that pertains to religion is a virtue of infinite value.
So much so that I made use of the word in order to propagate the face in the whole universe.
Look at that, Jesus made use of the word, isn't that fantastic?
It's the word of God that is spread throughout the whole earth.
And one who exercises himself in this serves as mouth to manifest my will to creatures.
Now there's a wonderful piece in Daniel chapter 12 from verse 3 where Daniel says that when
all history is over, we will rise again some to eternal glory and some to eternal shame.
And he says that those who have proclaimed the word of God will shine like stars for
all eternity.
Very interesting.
As he was saying this, I understood very well that this person was Jesus, this child.
And on hearing his clear voice, which I had not heard for so long, I felt myself rise
again from death to life.
I was waiting for him to finish speaking to tell him about my extreme needs.
But no, as soon as I stopped hearing his voice, he disappeared, in other words, he doesn't
want Louisa talking about her needs.
He only wants to talk about what's going on in the church and the world and that he and
Louisa together must suffer in order to try and do something about it.
So November the 5th, we're talking about the tree of life.
Very interesting this one.
This morning, my adorable Jesus made himself seen in my interior and he seemed to have
a tree planted in his sacred heart.
And it was so rooted in it that its roots rose from the center of his heart.
In some, it seemed to be born together with his heart and with the same nature.
I was amazed at seeing its beauty, its strikingness and its height, which seemed to touch the
heavens and its branches extended out to the furthest ends of the world.
Okay.
Now let me give you some references for the tree of life before we go on.
Proverbs 11.30, Proverbs 15.4.
Ignising the tree is Matthew 12.33.
The tree that is the mustard seed that fills the whole earth is Matthew 13 and the specific
verses 31, but it will be the verses before it as well.
And 1 Peter 2.4 says that Jesus is the tree of life.
So Jesus said, "My daughter, this tree was conceived together with me in the center of
my heart.
And from that moment I felt in my innermost heart all the good and the evil that man were
to do with this tree of redemption called the tree of life."
So I want to give you Genesis 2.9 where we meet the tree and the tree, the tree of good
and evil and the tree of life in the garden of Eden.
And I want to give you Sam 1 verse 3, and that is that people living a real life of relationship
with God are like trees as well.
So Jesus calls the tree of redemption, the tree of life, and he was actually raised on
a tree and he actually made his divine sacrifice for us on a tree.
In fact, all those souls who remain united to this tree will receive the life of grace
in time and when the tree has raised them well, it will administer to them the tree of glory
in eternity.
Now, I want to give you Revelation 2.7, Revelation 22 verse 2 and verse 14.
That is the bit about receiving glory in eternity.
"Yeah, what is not my sorrow?
Even though they cannot root the tree out, nor can they touch the trunk because the trunk
is Jesus himself, John 15, 1-5, 'I am the vine and you are my branches.'
But many of them try to cut some branches so that the souls may not receive life and
to take away from me all the glory and pleasure that this tree of life would have produced
from me."
And that was the complaint that Jesus made to Saul on the road to Damascus when he knocked
him down with a strike of lightning in Acts 9.4.
He said, "You are persecuting me."
In other words, trying to destroy the branches of the tree.
They couldn't destroy the tree.
When they tried to destroy the tree, of course, he rose from the dead.
So that meant that he was completely outside of our ability to destroy him anymore, but
they can try and destroy the branches of the tree.
So November 9, 1902, "While I was longing for my adorable Jesus, he came in the appearance
he had when his enemies were slapping him, covering his face with spit and blindfolding
him.
With admirable patience, he suffered everything.
Even more, it seemed he would not even look at them so much was he intent in his interior
on looking at the fruit that his sufferings would produce."
Now, for that, I want to give you Hebrews 12, too.
And it says that for the joy that was set before him, he endured the cross, despising
the shame.
Louisa said, "I admired everything with amazement, and Jesus told me my daughter.
In my operating and suffering, I never looked outside.
I always looked inside.
And whatever it might be, in seeing its fruit, I would not just suffer it, but I would suffer
everything with yearning and evidity."
Now, Louisa illustrates this very well in her meditations on the hours of the Passion.
For example, when Jesus is crowned with thorns, she describes him as sitting there quite peacefully
in all of this massive torture.
And he is trying to interiorly offer the crown that the father would give us back the crown
of life and that in taking the mace of kingship given to him with disgusting violations of
his person, that he wanted to give us back the ability to reign in life with him.
And he took the robe of mockery so he could give us, first of all, the robe of baptism
and then the robe of glory and so on and so on, that he was intent on what was happening
in his interior and what was happening exteriorly to him was the price he was prepared to pay.
On the other hand, completely opposite, man works in exactly the opposite way.
He doesn't look inside the work and see the fruit and he becomes easily bored and everything
bothers him and many times even it lacks what is doing good.
So we only look on the outside and we don't look at what we can do with this.
Now, Louisa isn't the only one who has told us that we must look to our interior for the
meaning of everything.
If you take St. Therese of Lesus, for example, she said that if a person picks up a pin off
the floor with the motive of pure love for God, that that person does more good than
all the projects on the planet.
The interior disposition makes all the difference to the value and meaning of the external action.
So let's look at this again.
Man is the opposite of Jesus.
In operating good, he doesn't look inside.
He doesn't look at the fruit.
He becomes easily bored and everything bothers him and at times he just gives up.
If he suffers, he easily loses his patience.
And if he does evil, not looking inside that evil, he does it with ease.
Now, do you see, by not looking at the interior and the root of everything, in good things,
we can absolutely make them useless, but in evil we can go to a terrible extent because
we're not looking at the source and the root.
And then he added, "Human beings do not want to convince themselves that life must be accompanied
by various circumstances of sufferings and of consolation.
Yet even plants and flowers will give them the example of this by remaining submitted
to wind, snow, hail, and heat.
In other words, our souls, as well as our bodies, need winters and summers.
We need the wind, we need the storms, we need the rain, we need the cold, we need the heat,
we need the change because what is inside of us is reflected out in the universe and
what is in the universe is reflected inside of us.
If you will read no other book, at least read the book of nature and you will learn what
you need to know."
So November the 16th, 1902, the word of God is joy, it's wonderful, isn't it?
I spent last night in great distress, Louisa said, I saw the confessor in the act of giving
me prohibitions and commands, everybody loves that, don't they?
Blessed Jesus came for a little and said, my daughter, the word of God is joy, I think
that's fantastic.
Now, and one who listens to the word of God but does not let it bear fruit with his works,
gives it a black shade and covers it with mud.
Now Saint James in chapter 5 of his letter will tell you the same thing that's completely
useless to listen to the word of God and then to walk away and forget about it, completely
useless.
So Jesus says here that if we don't put it into practice and let it bear its fruit,
it will give a black shade and will be covered with mud.
So I want to give you Sam 119, which is all about the word of God, is the longest Sam
in the book and I'll just give you a few verses, verse 74, 77, 92, 97 and 129.
We really need to look them up.
Then feeling much in suffering, Louisa said, I tried not to pay attention to what I was
seeing.
And all of a sudden the confessor came telling me that Monsignor commanded in an absolute
way, that the priest was not supposed to come anymore and to make me come out of my usual
state.
Oh yeah, to make me, the priest came every day to bring her out of her usual state of
not only ecstasy, but stiffness that her body was in.
So that was not going to happen anymore and so she would have to come out of it by herself.
Something which I had not been able to obtain for as many as 18 years, she says, in spite
of tears and prayers, so that the woman has been 18 years in the bed needing this help
and the Lord has absolutely insisted on the priest coming all the time.
Now the person that Louisa calls the Monsignor is what we would call the Bishop, okay?
So the Bishop is now putting his foot down and saying, I'm not going to spare a priest
to go to this song so a woman every single day, let her come out of it by herself, okay?
It's very easy for the Bishop to say that, locked up in his own house and all his comforts
and all the rest of it.
He doesn't know what's going on in Louisa, but he should know because the priests have
been reporting to him all the time, all the time, all the time.
But it took an awful long time for the bishops to accept that what was going on in Louisa
was actually real.
They want to just dismiss it then, okay, she's a holy person, okay, she's having these
visions, but leave us out of it, you know.
And if you've been with me since Volume 1, you realize how many times Jesus has told
them that he absolutely wants the priests involved because we're only on Volume 4.
And we have to wait until we get to Volume 11 and 12 for the full revelation of the
divine will to be made, and it's a public revelation made to the church and to the world
about the era that we have entered into, okay?
And so the church had to be involved because after all, it is the church of Christ.
So here's poor Louisa and again she's caught between two stools, and they're really going
to torture her again.
You know from Volume 1 that when she started having these visions and revelations, they
just thought she was looking for a notice.
And they even left her for three weeks just sitting there.
No food, no drink, no nothing, she could have died, and they would have been responsible.
So here we're back at this again.
And so Louisa said that she had asked the Lord for 18 years that the priest wouldn't
have to come anymore.
And now the man's senior, the bishop has decided he's not sending the priest and that's that.
And so Louisa says, "In fact, I confess before God that all the sufferings I've gone through
have not been true crosses for me, but delights and graces of God, but the soul and true cross
for me has been the coming of the priest.
This is the thorn in her side.
She has hated it.
Two Corinthians 12, seven.
St. Paul had a thorn in his side as well.
And the thorn in your side is something you absolutely do not want.
Many people think they know what their cross is, but your cross is something that you would
give to anybody anytime, anywhere under any conditions because it's so terrible.
And it's crucifying you.
So if you can carry something easily, it might be just a little trial, but it won't be your
cross."
"So knowing the impossibility of this outcome," she said, "from many years of experience,
my heart was lacerated by the fear that I might not be able to obey and that I would
do nothing but shed most bitter tears praying to that God who alone sees the depths of my
heart, that he would have pity on the position that I found myself in.
She's now absolutely between the absolute will of God and the absolute will of the bishop."
That's torture.
While praying in tears, I saw a flash of light and a voice said to me, "My daughter, to make
known that it is I, I will obey Him," and this is very important.
Both in the case of victim souls and their obedience to the Lord, God acknowledges the
authority of the church and the authority of the bishop and the authority of the priest.
When it comes to exorcisms, the devil acknowledges the authority of the church and the bishop
and the priest as well.
So they're able to command Him to leave.
It's very interesting.
So Jesus says, "To let them know that it is me, I will obey Him, and after I have given
him proofs of obedience, he will obey me."
In other words, the Lord will put his foot down.
And de Wiese said, "Lord, I fear very much that I may not be able to obey."
And he said, "Obedience releases the chains, and since it is a chain, it binds the divine
volition with the human and makes them one."
In such a way that the soul does not act with the power of her own will, but with the power
of the divine will.
So Jesus says to her, "Don't worry.
We will obey.
The divine will is in you and in me we are one, and so it will be the divine will that
will operate in you and she will see the divine will taking over.
Besides it's not you who will obey, it is I who will obey in you.
So here is the Lord obeying the church.
It should be the other way around."
Then all afflicted, he added, "My daughter, did I not tell you that keeping you in this
state of victim and starting this slaughter in Italy is almost impossible for me?
This is a warning shot across the bow for the bishop."
But you make me take Louisa to heaven and Italy goes down.
So I became a little bit more calm, she said, though I did not know how disobedience is going
to be carried out.
So in the next story, we continue this terrible struggle that she has.
So November the 17th, 1902, "As the usual hour came for me to be surprised by my usual
state to my great bitterness but such bitterness that I had never experienced anything similar
in my life, my mind was no longer able to lose consciousness."
Now when she says lose consciousness, she means going to ecstasy.
My life, my treasure, the one who formed all of my delight, my all-lovable Jesus was not
coming.
I tried to recollect myself as much as I could but I felt my mind so awake that I would neither
lose consciousness nor sleep.
So I would do nothing but break the break to my tears.
I did as much as I could to follow in my interior what I would do in the state of unconsciousness
of my senses.
In other words, in the state of ecstasy.
And one by one, I would recall his teachings, his words, and the way I was supposed to remain
always united with him.
But these were all darts that wounded my heart bitterly, saying to me, "After you have seen
him every day for fifteen years, now this is quite a revelation and this is Louisa herself
telling us what has been really happening.
After seeing him every day for fifteen years, sometimes more, sometimes less, sometimes
three or four times, sometimes once.
Sometimes he would speak to you, other times he would be silent.
But still you would see him and now you've lost him.
It's no wonder she wants only to go to heaven.
I mean, if you even saw the Lord thoroughly just once you would want to go to heaven,
your soul would just simply leap out of your body and go to him.
Because you're looking at infinite love, infinite mercy, infinite joy, infinite peace.
You couldn't stay here in all the misery that we have down here on the earth.
And she said, "Now I've lost him.
You don't see him anymore.
You no longer hear his sweet and gentle voice, everything is over for you.
My poor heart would become so filled with bitterness and sorrow that I can say that
my bread was sorrow and my drink was tears, that's Psalm 42 verses 1 to 4, "I've nothing
but tears for my bread, night and day, as they say to me all the day long, 'Where is
your God?'"
I was so filled with bitterness that not one drop of water could enter my throat.
Isn't that something?
These priests don't realize what they're dealing with and they don't realize that they could
kill her.
To this another thorn was added, "Often times I had said to my adorable Jesus, 'Oh, how
I fear about my state, that it is just me, that it's all fantasy, that it is pretense.'
And he would say to me, 'Remove these fears, for you will see then that days will come
in which, in spite of any effort and sacrifice that you would make to go into ecstasy, you'll
not be able to do it.'"
That's in volume two, he told her that.
"But in spite of all this," she said, "I felt calmness in my interior.
Now that's the big grace that she's getting, that she's not disturbed.
For at least I was obeying, though at the cost of my life."
So I thought that things would have to continue this way, convincing myself that our Lord no
longer wanted me in that state.
He had used the bishop to have him give me that obedience.
Then after two days had passed, now don't forget she is not taking even one sip of water.
In the evening I was about to make my adoration to the crucifix when a flash of light came
before my mind.
I felt my heart being opened, now notice only God can do it, she can't do it.
And a voice saying to me, "I will keep you suspended for a few days, and then I will
make you fall again, that is into ecstasy."
And Louisa said, "Lord, will you not make me come round yourself if you make me fall?"
And he said, "No, it is a decree of my will to use the work of the priest to make you come
round from this state of sufferings.
And if they want to know why, let them come to me and ask me.
My wisdom is incomprehensible, as Paul tells us in Romans chapter 9, and has many unusual
ways for the salvation of souls.
But even though it is incomprehensible, if they want to find the reason, let them go
deep, for they will find it bright like the sun.
My justice is like a cloud pregnant with rain, thunders and lightning, and in you it found
a dam, so as not to unload itself over the people.
So let them not want to advance the time of wrath."
Oops, there's another shot across the bow for the bishop.
And the time of wrath is Revelation chapter 6 to 11.
But this is 1902, and the immediate time of wrath would be the First World War.
And Louisa said, "Only for me was this chastisement reserved, with no hope of being freed of it.
You've given so many graces to other souls, they have suffered greatly for love of you,
yet they have no need of the work of the priest.
And the voice continued, 'You will be freed, not now, but when the slaughters begin in
Italy.'
Third shot across the bow for the bishop."
This was for me another reason for sorrows, and most bitter tears, Louisa said, so much
so that my most lovable Jesus having compassion for me moved in my interior.
Let's Luke 17 21, the kingdom of God is within you, and 1 Corinthians 3, 16.
So he moved in my interior as though placing a veil before what he had told me, and without
letting himself be seen, he let me hear his voice saying to me, 'My daughter, come to
me.
Do not want to afflict yourself.
Let us move just as a way for a little, and let us give room for love.
Otherwise, you will succumb.'
He knows very well how fragile human nature actually is, and Louisa is continuously being
pushed to the very edge.
What is demanded of her is heroism beyond heroism.
"Listen to me," Jesus said, "I have many things to teach you.
Do you think I have finished speaking to you?"
No, this is only volume 4, and there are 32 more volumes to go.
'No,' he said, 'I have not finished.'
And Louisa said, 'And since I was crying in my eyes had become two rivers of tears.
He added, 'Do not cry, my beloved, but rather give me audience.
This morning I want to hear a mass together with you, teaching you the way that you must
hear it.'
Isn't that fantastic?
'And so he kept speaking, and I would follow him.
But since I could not see him, my heart was split by the pain continuously.
From time to time, to stop me crying, he would call me repeatedly, teaching me something
about his passion, explaining something to me, or teaching me how to do what he did in
his interior during the course of his passion, which I refrain from writing now, reserving
it for another time if he so pleases.
And this went on for two more days.
So I want to leave it there just for the moment.